what up guys welcome to the just hurly
things YouTube channel where I cover
this week's treachery debauchery and
craziness before I start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel ring that
notification Bell let's get started so
today guys I got into a Twitter Warf you
know me I'm always beefing on Twitter
and a lot of times people take two
screenshots of mine and really
misconstrue what I'm saying I have been
misconstrued so many times an example of
this was the idea that I pushed
vasectomies okay this was months ago I
was tweeting about the risks versus
rewards of vasectomies now I would never
push someone to do it but my point was
that marrying a woman in 2023 is equally
as risky as a vasectomy and the problem
is the tradcons get really mad because
honestly what I'm saying is
absolutely true true true true true true
but whenever men are in the position of
power when it comes to reproduction
people get mad people get enraged and
whenever I say something that is
uncomfortable but true they get mad they
get mad at me I'm not saying to go do it
but [__] it's equally as risky to marry
a woman can you blame them can you BL
anyways so I decided to make the case
that the modern housewife is actually
very lazy in 2023 the modern housewife
literally sucks they're not like the
women of the past that had their own
cookbooks that really served the men the
modern housewife thinks that men should
serve her and what you'll typically see
from the modern housewife is she
believes that she is the prize and that
she is so special and amazing and
awesome and the modern housewife
believes that her husband should make
all of the money and that she should get
to stay home look pretty and really just
have everything taken care of for her
now Rachel Wilson says let me get this
straight the entitled women on this app
want their husband to go to work and
provide for them so they can be
Homemakers but they also expect their
husband to help them with the homemaking
after they get home from the job that
allows them to be a homemaker
GTFO Helen says marriage and family
should be a partnership and not
indentured servitude Rachel Wilson says
so if my husband works so I can stay
home but I have to do the housework
that's servitude have you ever
questioned the propaganda and this is my
point guys if you look up a day in my
life as a housewife what you'll
typically see is women doing activities
that benefit her real and true
femininity we've talked about this has
nothing to do with the way you look it
has nothing to do with fashion what it
has to do with serving your family your
community and God and when you see the
typical housewife what happens is she
does yoga she does Pilates typically
they have caked on makeup typically it
it comes from a lot of women that have
this I am a princess mentality and what
I'm tired of seeing is modern women that
that are absolutely
lazy yes just because you are a woman it
does not entitle you to a free ride in
life you should be providing value to
your husband and your family and the
fact that we have so many tradcon women
arguing that their husband should do
chores actually shows how not tradcon
they are how bad of Housewives they are
because it they're arguing over chores
this is the same argument I had with the
left with Destiny so Rachel Wilson says
this is the attitude we're dealing with
these women are programmed
NPCs Intrigue verse the key is Choice a
woman should have the choice to work or
stay home and not have it dictated by
someone else wrong see that that
mentality right there is wrong it should
absolutely be dictated by her husband
why would you not defer authority to
your husband and my question is women
wait till 30 to get married fine they
have one kid fine why what are you doing
all day with your time if your one kid
is in public
school I mean I'm not trying to be rude
I'm just asking the question so Paul
Elum says Nope women should work they
should not have the choice to be a
parasite now this really I retweeted
this because I thought it was an
interesting topic now this really
enraged the tradcons they started saying
Pearl but don't you think the mother
should be home with the kids well yeah
but the modern housewife isn't even home
with their
kids she sends them to public school
seven hours a day typically they're in
some after school activity so sports
music whatever it is and typically it's
one
kid I mean at that point you might as
well get a job [__] and that's my point
women want conservative and traditional
outcomes but they don't want to do what
comes with it they don't want to
homeschool the kids they don't want to
have a bunch of kids fine I'm not even
saying you can't do that but my point is
if you're not a traditional conservative
wife and you're not willing to do what
traditional conservative wives do why do
you deserve traditional conservative
wife treatment you have one kid that
attends public school for seven hours a
day get a job [__] sorry and if you
look at culture and what we think of
when we think of soccer moms we think of
things like Pilates when we think of
Housewives I think of a bunch of women
that just drink wine after work now I
know there's Exceptions there are women
that absolutely serve their husbands but
it's the exception it's not the norm and
when you talk to truly traditional women
they know it's the exception and not the
norm so I've been arguing with this
chick shoe on shoe on head I don't
really and she's pedaling propaganda and
here here's the problem just because you
get to Pedal propaganda doesn't mean
you're correct homemaking and caring for
children is work it's a lot of work and
it's very important work it really is a
lot of works and many times a thankless
job so I disagree and I said this in
2023 it's really not do you have any
idea what an easy time it is to be alive
no sorry guys in 2023 the average woman
has 1.5 children she has one kid the kid
typically goes to public school and you
know now there saying that it's more
common for women to drink alcohol than
men and I've heard from AA members the
most common alcoholic is actually the
wine mothers the mothers that drink wine
every single night this is not uncommon
what is more common is to see these
Botox foreheads and these Homemakers
that are desperately clinging to their
youth I totally believe that homemaking
is amazing but not the way we do it in
2023 you want to have one kid that goes
to public school uh it's time to go do
something because what I keep seeing is
women that are demanding princess
treatment without being the type of
women that deserve princess treatment
and who really deserves princess
treatment you know what I mean like I
just grew up in a family that valued
hard work it didn't matter if you're a
woman it didn't matter if you were a man
you worked hard and you were a
contributing member of the family and
now women think it's the men's job to
serve them I deserve to be home all day
and just do nothing no no no not Pearl
this is why everyone thinks you're a
libfem plant by the way yes I am just a
libfem a libfem plant ah these crazy
people I said the average woman has 1.5
kids and sends them to school 7 hours a
day at 5 years old a part-time job is
really going to kill her most modern
mothers are not these selfless women we
portray they are generally just
lazy Am I Wrong Am I Wrong in 2023 most
women are just as useless at home as
they are at work and so then she puts
she they always do this I'll tweet like
10 tweets with a lot of context and they
never put in the context they just put
two screenshots next to each other no
ladies none of your jobs are that
important society would probably be more
efficient if we all left the workforce
tomorrow two things can be true at once
women are typically pretty useless at
work they're also pretty useless at home
I've heard of multi-millionaires that do
not get sex from their wives imagine
being a homemaker I mean you have one
primary job one job we can't even do
that and generally most women have
gotten princess treatment from the time
they were a child and really have never
had to work hard for anything and have
no grasp on reality so they go to the
work course or they go bother their
husbands and do the exact same thing
useless absolutely useless I would
actually be for women going home if they
were homeschooling their kids if they
were having five children if they were
actually being contributing members to
the family but now you see women
spending their family's income on Botox
spending their family's income on the
latest fashion trends and really just
doing a lot of behaviors that focus on
themselves they go to the gym
it's me me me me me they're much more
concerned with themselves their career
their social life than their actual
children so does the modern mother
deserve to be a homemaker hell no hell
no and at some point women have to
realize that we have made our bed and
you can either lie in it and accept the
responsibility that comes with it or
demand prices that most women will not
get most women will not be Homemakers it
is absolutely better for the kids if the
mom stays home but what you have is
Homemakers that don't even spend a lot
of time with their children so what's
the point at that point go get a job you
have one kid so I say most women's jobs
in the workforce are useless no ladies
none of your jobs are that important
society would be more efficient if we
all left the workforce tomorrow yes but
that's not reality women are not leaving
the workforce I have a tweet that
further explains this you are proving my
point most women in 2023 are just as
useless in the workforce as they are at
home modern mothers want traditional
outcomes but refuse to get married
before a 30 have a bunch of kids and
learn traditional skills that would be
useful to a man the idea that the women
that deserve to be housewives are common
is absolutely propaganda pushed by women
and simps to prove that they're more
special and more important than they are
if women have five kids a cookbook and
can homeschool then fine stay at home
but by and large women are having one
kid sending them to public school and
then demanding to be a housewife [__]
get to
work yes and I just just I cannot stand
this new level of just lazy women I I
was an A and really the one thing
there's there's pros and cons to women's
Athletics like on one hand it kind of
messes up your hormones on one hand it
kind of you know there's a lot of
feminists in it but the one thing it
does teach you is the value of hard work
and ever since I was a kid my dad just
really instilled us that you work hard
for what you want in life what I am
seeing more and more is women that are
absolutely entitled they don't have any
housewife skills they're not willing to
homeschool their children they're not
willing to even really spend time with
their kids yet They want to be put on
this pedestal as a housewife these same
women will tell you how amazing of wives
and mothers they are what they don't
realize that in itself is a tell if
you're going around telling everybody
that you are an amazing wife and mother
do you know what that does remember it
puts the focus on me me me feminine
traditional women want the focus on
their husband husbands they sing their
husbands Praises they are not talking
about themselves see again she's
mischaracterizing my argument stay at
home mom lazy get a job have a job
useless and leave the workforce what I'm
actually saying is women start providing
some value
somewhere
Jesus like it's like I'm just tired of
the lazy women I'm tired of seeing lazy
housewives that have wine a clock every
day that have one kid and send their
kids to public school we it it's like
the men will give you one job raise the
kids and we can't even do that you get
these kids that come out with this woke
feminist propaganda because you couldn't
do the one job that you have so then
it's like okay maybe go get a job and we
get these useless Human Resources
project manager jobs and then start
crying about not getting paid enough
what I am tired of is the entitlement if
you want housewife treatment do the
things that Housewives do do but until
we start doing that which across the
board women are not no getting married
is not just a free ride for life so I
said the modern stay-at-home wife adds
very little to their husbands they are
not like the women of the past who had
seven kids cooked meals from scratch and
serve their husband's needs and what
really proved this was just how many
tradcon women and even simp men were
arguing about if the husband should do
chores
this is from the right this is from the
right it's like these ladies have one
job Paul elim says total [__] the
society Falls all over itself glorifying
even defying motherhood we tell
ridiculous lives like it is the hardest
job in the world being a mother and
other [__] yeah I'm so tired of
hearing this this is propaganda it is
not the hardest job in the world if it
was then why are why are babysitters
paid like 15 bucks an
hour women just want special treatment
you know what else isn't that hard
housework laundry cooking I mean [__] we
have room bus nowadays we have air
fryers you have easy make meals we live
in the easiest time to be alive and
women want more and more and more credit
feminine traditional women are not
worried about credit they give their
husband all of the credit and that's why
so many of these fake tradcon women they
tell on themselves in the way that they
talk because they care so much about
glorifying themselves and that messes up
the natural order of the world they talk
about themselves like they are a god of
some sort the hardest job in the world I
mean really that's almost
Godlike it is men who go out without
thanks and indeed their efforts to work
and provide are demonized because it
takes time away from family get real yes
and they punish the men for working and
providing for their family and letting
their wife do the easy job the men do
the hard job the wife do the easy job
and then they blame them for not being
there enough and give the mom custody
then you have simp men that come in and
say oh they wav the finger at the
husband and say that he just wasn't an
alpha enough leader and what you see is
you see women that are terrible with
money even if the woman makes more they
have the value of the man helping them
with money because by and large when
women get money we spend it do you know
how many celebrities and actresses go
broke and if you don't want to go broke
and you are new to investing and have
savings that you need to protect right
now with the Middle East War the Ukraine
war and maybe even Taiwan soon you need
a Playbook that is safe allocate some
gold now and avoid the frenzied Panic of
the unprepared when fear Reigns gold
protects the wise Noble gold Investments
offers a free 5 ounce America of the
beautiful coin with IAS this month
Shield your savings with a noble gold
Investments Ira go to Noble gold
investments.com now that's noblegold
investments.com the only gold company
that I trust the worst part with these
Housewives is a guys do you know how
many Housewives and how many just okay
over the last couple of years I have
interviewed thousands of people these
are the conclusions that I come to from
interviewing thousands of people women
leave their husbands for the stupidest
and dumbest reasons I have ever heard in
my life very few times have I heard
actually legit reasons for divorce and I
thought about the most common reason
that I get for leaving the father of
your children or their husband and it is
that these women outgrew him the amount
of women that I have met that casually
destroyed their entire families because
they outgrew their husbands is genuinely
depressing we tweeted yesterday and what
you typically get from the modern
mothers that are coping and can't accept
the fact that they actually made the
wrong most selfish decision that they
have ever made in their life oh let me
just put my kid at every statistical
disadvantage oh let me only see both of
my parents half the time in the month oh
let me make my kid more likely to run
away from home more likely to drop out
of school and more likely to be abused
because of my feelings of outgrowing him
Miss doso says divorce does not break a
family it only transforms it and we see
the women coping no the data does not
support your thesis it does not
it significantly impacts the children
and the Children of Divorce will back
this up men women can't you just learn
to get along why do we have to break up
the family and hurt the innocent people
the kids the kids and it's so it's so
funny women are so self-centered that
they they use every single cope to make
their selfish decision not sound like a
selfish decision paladin says men can
change like women can too the issue is
that hous making means stability and
growth isn't good or bad but it
certainly isn't stable it is volatile by
default it would make a lot of sense
that the hormonal gender is more
volatile and gross the default is for
men to stabilize the family so yeah you
get what you asked for and it isn't
enough by the way change isn't growth
and many think it is another topic
though yeah I mean men can change too
but they're not destroying their
families by and large you know what's
funny when women win the lottery they
tend to divorce their husbands when men
win the lottery they tend to stay Emily
web says outgrew means they realize they
needed better or different there's
nothing wrong with that you see how
deluded this is there's nothing wrong
okay what is meat really guys I honestly
think I could get along with anybody if
you give me enough time I really do so
what is what is you needed different
really it was a want getting the husband
or the wife that you want is a luxury
okay and sometimes you you make your bed
and you you maybe didn't pick the
husband that she wanted or whatever and
women of the past used to just lie in it
and just deal with it and life wasn't
all about relation like the women of the
past just dealt with their choices and
made the best of it because they cared
more about their family their community
and their children but the women of
today do not care about their children
they care more about their feelings and
what they want and what they need really
before the 1900s the collective was the
most important the family was the most
important but now we are pedal and told
these lies that it's all about me and my
feelings and what I want and that's not
what life should be about Sandy says I
think it's important to understand the
destruction occurs a lot sooner than the
divorce papers and it is not always in
the couple's control this seems to be a
crucial point that escapes
many okay let me get this straight
filing for
divorce is not in the couple's control
learning to get along with somebody
is not in your control
really all right so now we have another
simp simp simp simp simp simp simp simp
simp simp simp simp here's I could be
like Oprah there's a simp there's a simp
there's another simp simp simp
simp because these men do not help us
they are just Liars because they want to
look good to everybody and they want to
Pander to women and get laid what about
the masses what about the masses of men
who cheated on their wives because their
wives boobs started sagging and the
younger women at their jobs flirted with
them I have never heard that story in my
life I have never heard a story of a guy
that said oh my wife's boob started
sagging so let me just but do you know
what story I've heard a million times
men that have been in sexless marriages
for years and then she and we never talk
about it it's always oh he cheated he's
evil but we never talk about why he
cheated the nagging woman or the nagging
wife that demasculate her husband for
years for years you know women of the
past used to work through cheating and
you could see it in the culture I mean
look at the song Jolene by Dolly Parton
she was begging the side chick not to
take her husband she's saying please
please I love this man I love it but now
oh it's the victim he's evil I'm amazing
and awesome and special I'm done I'm
done with this [__] you I can't
Pander I can't lie all of these simps
are just liars and I can't stand it and
I'm not going to read this stuff anymore
and not call it out you're a simp sir s
i m p s that should be the no new song
you know how they got like the
promiscuous or like the
what was that Fergie song it's like
where they spell it out someone should
make a song where it's like you're a s
you're a you're s m p simp thank you
honestly Pearl Jessica
Jones honestly Pearl God didn't bother
creating women to just cook and clean
for men and if women are so useless
compared to men why not just give men
the ability to procreate without us in
general since the majority of life on
Earth requires a male and a female to
create life well [__] Jessica they're
starting to you know if I say that
children are less competent than adults
is that an insult women are less
competent by and large than men
occasionally you have a prodigy kid that
just is very good and you're like wow
what a what a child but it's still a
child the other thing she
says why not just give men the ability
to procreate without us they're working
on it I mean guys all we had to do all
we had to do was provide some value in
the world and the best way that women
when we got freedom found to provide
value was only fans and sex work it's
like I honestly think if men had kids by
themselves the kids would turn out
better than what we have now I I know I
know we have all these mental health
issues we have all of these kids that
are grown up to be criminals rude
disrespectful it's because all these
moms just outgrow their husbands and
think huh let me just let me just be by
myself oh it's going to be amazing and
let me Rob let me Rob the guy through
child support and alimony for a lifetime
amazing let me just have my free ride we
have 50 years of women that just love
having a free ride I'm tired of it I'm
tired of the laziness you don't have to
be a lazy bimbo ladies you really don't
so I had a question I wanted to ponder
this question so I had a tweet so I had
a question I wanted to know is Beauty in
general a blessing or a curse and so I
asked the men to list your top five
hottest women from the 80s 90s and early
2000s and I actually wanted to follow
the lifespan of some of these
celebrities I want I'm going to guess
how their lives turned out some of them
I'm going to know some of them I don't
and so we took some of the lists that
the guys gave us don't shoot the
messenger this is not my list this is
just some of the ones that people gave
us and I want to see how these women's
lives turned out and if they ended end
up married so Kim
Kardashian is currently dating NFL star
Odell
Beckham okay before that she dated Pete
Davidson before that she dated
Kanye before that she was married to or
sorry she was married to Kanye then
married to Chris
Humphries then baseball player Gabriel
Aubrey or then she was dating Reggie
Bush and then she was married to Damon
Thomas
so on one hand they do get access to the
highest quality of men but here you see
it's very tough for women at the upper
levels of beauty Fame and attention to
settle down the next woman that the men
listed was Angelina Jolie so Angelina
Jolie is currently rumored to be dating
Irish actor Paul muscal from 1996 to
1999 she dated Johnny Lee Miller from
2000 to 2003 she dated Billy Bob thoron
and from 2014 to 2019 she was married to
the one and only Brad hit and so you
start to ask the question is beauty
really a blessing or a curse because a
common thing that I've gotten from men
is women that are ranked from eights to
tens tend to be useless because they've
lived their whole life on easy mode both
of these women had four children um I
believe or four plus children and both
of these women are still really living
like they're in their 20s um and the
reason is because they're beautiful
enough that they really still can the
next woman we have is Pamela Anderson
she dated Tommy Lee from 1995 to 1998
then she dated Kid Rock from 2006 to
2007 then oh I get okay she's pretty
attractive what did she do to her hair
there why do women do I cannot stand it
when women cut off their hair it does
not look good okay she dates Rick
Salomon from 2007 to 2008 and 2014 to
2015 John Peters in 2020 and then
they're actually a good couple they look
good together she got can work out and
now she's dating Dan hayhurst from 2020
to 2022 okay so right now she is married
it's only been two years but if I had to
predict it I don't really see it working
out um but again you really don't see
like a long successful happy
relationship here you see a string of
bad relationships after bad
relationships okay so Heidi Clo's
current relationship Heidi Clum is
currently married to musician Tom Colts
they have been married since
2019 um before that in 1997 to 2002 um
she dated Rick hipo uh before that she
dated
Flavio bror these women really do have
types like like a wealthy old guy 2004
to 2005 she dated lavio and seal she
dated the longest oh maybe she doesn't
have a type look at that 2005 to 2014
wait go go back through these again I
was thinking because she sort of had a
type there like that they kind of were
the same type go back W very wide range
wide range so out of the four we've done
originally two are married right now so
Heidi CL and Pamela Anderson both have
been married for two years so I think
it's kind of still too soon to see how
it plays out so the next woman that they
list is Natalie Portman and Natalie
Portman is married to a French
choreographer Benjamin m Milli P from
2012 to present so she's been married
the longest I would say out of the four
that's the closest to a like I would say
a success because I don't I don't think
you can really I don't know two years is
just a little too early for me to
qualify that you know she got the
happily ever after Natalie Portman she
really has a very classic Beauty she
really does that's like a wife Beauty
before her current husband she was
rumored to have
dated what
the these women's types let me tell you
a musician mobie um and before that she
had a brief relationship with actor Jake
Gyllenhaal 2006 oh wow that guy Taylor
Swift dated and wrote all these songs
about him I only know him from Taylor
Swift's um
song oh he was so pissed is there
someone before that I'm going to
qualify success is 10 years married
maybe plus so the last person we have is
Selma Heek and she is currently married
to a
billionaire well I'm gonna say it was a
blessing for her uh from 2009 to present
so she's been married the longest it's
so interesting the women that the men
pick as the most beautiful women and
like the women that I would pick because
honestly I think the only woman I would
pick from this maybe Natalie
pman Angelina Jolie maybe Heidi Clum
okay but it's interesting because I
wouldn't I wouldn't picked this one
before that she was linked to actor
Edward Norton 1999 to 2000 and before
that she was engaged to actor Josh Lucas
200 oh okay she's actually quite
beautiful there I'm I'm going back and
forth guys engaged to actor Josh Lucas
2003 to 2004 so let's see out of the
five women that we did four were married
so I would guess that two are married
long enough for it to count is it a
blessing or a curse to be insanely
beautiful do you think most of these
women will have Happy Endings let me
know in the comments it's an idea I'm
kind of playing with because I could
really argue both sides on one hand
these women do have access to the men
that women typically respect where the a
average woman typically does not have
the same access and ability to get
commitment but on the other hand these
women have access to so many different
types of men that are on such a high
level that I do think hypergamy will
kind of kick in for a lot of them and
sometimes when women are in those
situations they choose chaos and right
now there is chaos in the markets oil
and stocks and just when you thought it
was safe and interest rates were Rising
new threats come out of nowhere tensions
are boiling from Asia to Europe Europe
and adaptation is the key to
safeguarding your wealth you may not
have considered gold before and it's not
speculation but insurance and right now
you need some insurance Noble gold
Investments has been protecting
investors for years from disasters with
precious metals so if you are worried it
might be time to take a fresh look at
gold and silver gold is a proven Safe
Haven shield for your portfolio and a
volatility balance against uncertainty
if it helps Noble gold investment is
offering a free 5 oce America the
beautiful coin with its new IAS this
month if you open your Noble gold
Investments Ira or 401K rollover you can
claim your coin today remember crisis
bruise portfolios waivers but Golds
insulate secure yourself against threats
go to Noble gold investments.com now
that's noblegold investments.com the
only gold company that I trust so as
I've said women are utterly useless in
the workforce absolutely useless they
provide little to no value um there are
exceptions as I've said I I don't know
why I feel the need to say there are
always exceptions but most women have
lived their life on easy mode and have
easy cushy office jobs where men are
doing the majority of the work and what
happens is these women go to college and
think they're so special important and
smart and they have all these skills and
they typically do not so I'm going to
play a Tik Tock of a woman talking about
this struggle let's pull it up for
anyone ripping that girl apart saying
the job Market's not that bad earlier
this year I'm looking for a job okay I
applied to over 300 jobs didn't hear
back from anyone like anything and
everything I was applying to because I'm
desperate right finally I hear back from
one job and it's perfect it's like a
social media position for a baseball
organization and I love baseball and I
do social media so I'm like this is
perfect so I go to an interview rock it
I'm like this job is mine he says I want
to do a second interview so I go to my
second interview at this point I asked
about the salary because he said it's a
full-time job with a salary and he's
like yes I want to do one more interview
with you I'm I'll get you the numbers at
that interview so I said okay so I go to
the third interview and he says it's
between you and one other candidate but
I'm going to go through with both of you
after that I'll call you and let you
know if the job is yours so I said okay
I get a call from him saying the job is
yours if you want it and I said I still
need to know the numbers I need to know
if I can afford to live and he says yep
I'll shoot you the proposal so he texts
me the proposal and it offers me $500 a
month $500 a month he says the schedule
is super flexible so if you need to work
another job we can work around that I
said that's not what full-time means and
frankly you just wasted so much of my
time that obviously I have to decline
this offer so I move on the next weekend
I post on my Tik Tok story that I'm not
doing anything that night I don't have
plans and he texts me at 11:00 p.m.
saying hey and I wait till the morning
to respond I'm like did you mean to text
me this and he says yeah I saw you
weren't doing anything so I thought I'd
ask if you wanted to grab a drink so I
said that's [__] weird you just you
just [__] me over so bad what the [__]
so I post about it on my spam account
next thing I know a girl messages me and
she says hey was this guy's name blank
and I said how the [__] did you know
that she said my best friend and him
were in a long-term relationship and
broke up around the time that this
happened for you so what night did he
say send you that text and I tell her
and she says that night they got into a
huge fight where he was arrested on two
counts of assault and battery one of
them being strangulation so I Google his
[__] mug shot and sure enough there
it is he lost his current job and the
organization that he was starting and
that was just the first interview I
heard back from the second one was
trying to scam me into giving him my
credit so that he could open a business
under my name because he defaulted on
loans and didn't have credit of his own
so yeah the job market really is that
bad
okay one this is the wildest story this
is the wildest story but women tend to
believe things that are too good to be
true and my question is why would a
athletic organization want a college
grad with no experience that's kind of
that's kind of my first thought second
thing I kind of question why are you
like going through the trouble of like
getting into his drama it kind of just
seems like a lot but my my more my
this is just a crazy story so I'm
actually more of the point I'm making is
things are bad for modern women they are
in a bunch of debt most of them have no
real skills most of them have lived life
on easy mode and are now unemployed
they're now in a man's world and they do
not know how to deal with it and the
comment section backs this up Victoria
I've been trying since January and I've
lost count of how many jobs I've applied
to I have two master's degrees and no
one cares or offers above 40K yes
because your skills are not worth and
that's the funny thing that's the funny
thing so she goes around she goes around
okay now my first job out of college it
was making like 42k plus commission but
it was a really hard job guys it was um
well I mean hard job is relative but it
was it was like sales and most people
just don't make it in sales it was
selling like the worst thing you could
ever sell which is like copers and we
couldn't get women like they wanted
women to work there women do better in
sales than men typically but women
wouldn't do it because they didn't want
to do a hard job so these women they
want Human Resources marketing they want
these like easy cushy jobs and they get
mad when they're paid $500 a month you
know it used to be that you would
actually work for free and get skills
and then apply later you know I've had
you know I don't even think that's
unreasonable like I offered um I never
did an unpaid internship because I just
got lucky like every place I applied to
offered to pay me but there if I really
wanted to work somewhere I would
absolutely work for free
until they could they could figure out
how to pay me um because really like
guys once you offer value to a company
and make it so you make their life
easier the money comes and that's why
like in my life I've always focused on
learning skills and I just figured the
money would come later Alex K killed MAA
I said I have a master's degree and the
most I've been offered is $18 I make
more as a receptionist and a server this
Market is wild but see see how they
immediately blame the market instead of
their skills they say it's the job
market oh no play people are hiring
people are hiring they're absolutely
hiring but what they are not hiring for
is useless women with a master's degree
and no skills yam mama says I have a
master's degree and five years of
experience in my field I was making $20
an hour at the start of the year but you
see this boobs out hoop earrings it's
the Modern Woman look it's the Modern
Woman look at heavy makeup boobs out
hoop earrings demanding more pay for
little work women um how many of them
appli to be a plumber electrician or
work in an oil rig women want the
benefits of being in a man's world but
they don't want the responsibility that
comes with it most women are absolutely
useless in the workforce absolutely
useless and they will cry on the
internet and basically tell on
themselves and tell them how useless
they are you see women and making money
off of sex work only fans because that
is the only way they can figure out how
to provide value to the market and then
we have these women that are living an
absolute delusion an example of that is
I saw a morbidly obese woman talking
about
insults imagine imagine being morbidly
obese and having the
audacity the audacity to [__] on
incels I mean at least the incel you
know
most incels or whatever are just kind of
nerdy scrawny guys at least they're not
obese anyways let's pull it up can you
explain what an incel is so an incel is
just like someone who is involuntarily
celibate that loser sitting on Reddit
for 23 hours a day um with cheetah dust
and empty Mountain Dew cans all around
them and it just has a real stank smell
that is involved with these people
because because I'm just going to P you
an image and like the Fedora is a little
crusty and the the beard the the neck
beard is strong but the facial hair is
weak and there's a ball spot in the back
and you can just and you can just see
the Fedora just hanging on for dear life
and he's sitting there mut muttering
under his breath about how like Jessica
Alba's ugly right you know that's what
you're talking
about so this woman has the audacity to
talk about incels really an incel
way better than that that is disgusting
Jesus like I i' take it on the treadmill
but I don't even think she can get on it
I don't even think she could like I
would say maybe start like walking oh
this is crazy but that's how delusional
she is that's how crazy that is and the
comment section picked this up
immediately they said I don't think
she's in the position to talk about
somebody's
Health
yes um she thinks she's on the same
level as the other girl I don't know
what she thinks but I don't know how you
could call them losers I mean there's
nothing more loser likee than being your
prime years and being morbidly obese
this is the same woman that would say
calling her fat is a hate crime I just
don't understand how these these chicks
have the audacity it's like the audacity
you are morbidly
obese I you got to get off the podcast
it's time to start start walking all
right okay guys thank you so so much for
watching and guys I am under threat of
getting kicked off of this platform
every single day so make sure you sign
up for our email list in case something
ever happens um we did recently get a
warning strike on the channel because
you know I talked about and it was
actually funny it was from that that
video like we are not gays I reacted to
it they took it down they gave me a a
warning so you know I always know that
this is something that could happen so
make sure you sign up for our email list
and comment below if you have something
you want to say and you want your
comment to be read next video the top
comment from last video was mad respect
for your unwavering dedication to create
topnotch content from Maria your nice F
I think this is a troll account guys um
but make sure you guys like the video on
your way out subscribe to the channel
and I'll talk to you next time